I sensed some confusion coming out of
the last video an inferior good so I
thought I would do another one so let's
make let's assume that there's three
cars in the market and what I want to do
this is I sense that some people thought
that I was suggesting that a car in
general isn't inferior good and that's
not what I was saying I was saying if we
lived in a reality where everyone owned
a car a car was a necessity for life and
that is true in much of the developed
world I was saying that the cheapest car
in the market might be considered an
inferior good and to think about that
let's just think about the entire
population so let's say this line this
line represents the entire population in
our place in our developed country where
everyone owns a car and let's say let's
say let's represent this car with blue
so let's say maybe a third of the people
a third of the people right now have
that car let's say a good chunk of the
people have this midsize sedan this is
probably the car that most people most
people would like to have it's a little
bit safer it's a little bit larger so
it's a more powerful engine and so this
is where most people are sitting this is
where most people are sitting and then
you have this ultra this kind of luxury
you have this luxury car or Rolls Royce
maybe and so that a very small segment
so this end of the this end of the line
is the poor so this is the poor in our
population and this is the rich this is
the rich right over here so this is at
some given income level and maybe we
could we could say this is true at a
particular price point but we'll see
what we're going to talk about is the
general impact on demand so on the
entire curve at any given price point
always assuming that this is the most
expensive this is in between and this is
the least expensive now what happens if
income goes up from here income goes up
well the very poorest they're not going
to be able to necessarily just trade up
to this midsize sedan yet although
they'll maybe have more income for other
things or maybe they can get a nicer
version of this but for the most part
they're still going to be driving this
car but at kind of the boundary right
over here if incomes do go up there will
be people who now can afford the midsize
car and that's what they want and so
these people might start buying the
mid-sized car and then what will happen
over here well maybe there's a few
people at the boundary over here they
now have the money to afford this very
expensive car and it suits their taste
and so they also a very small proportion
also grows there so what happened here
when income went up income went up the
quantity demanded the quantity demanded
demanded at a particular price point for
this smallest car went down but the
demand for this mid-sized car went up it
took a much bigger chunk out of this
blue than a chunk was taken out of it by
the orange and also the demand for this
very expensive car and this very
expensive car went up and that was it at
a particular price point but assuming
that this is the most expensive this is
the the middle and this is the cheapest
expensive this would be true of probably
any price point and so we have this
phenomenon that when income went up the
quantity demanded at multiple price
points for this car so let me draw its
actual demand curve so this car right
over here this is price this over here
is demand if it's old demand curve looks
something like this if it's old demand
curve looks something like this we're
saying and maybe you know when we
thought about this at first we're
thinking of we were thinking of the
price point right over here we noticed
when income went up at that particular
price point the quantity demanded went
down and that would be true pretty much
any price point assuming that this was
that this is always the cheapest car so
at any price point you would have a
decrease in demand when remember when we
talk about a decrease in demand we're
talking about a shift of the entire
curve we're not talking about just one
particular quantity now there's another
interesting question that was asked and
and it goes a very it was it's a very
nice and subtle thing to think about I
keep drawing these shifting demand
curves and if at least I understand the
question properly the question is well
does the Ault does a curve when it
shifts does doesn't necessarily shift
perfectly or - sometimes it change does
it shift more at one price point or
another and the simple answer is it can
it in fact in very few circumstances
would it
we be a perfect shift depending on the
price point you're at it would probably
shift a little bit different so the
actual shape of the curve might change
while it's shifting but anyway going
back to this so we see that this this
this cheap car right here had the
unusual property that when incomes went
up the demand curve shifted to the left
and that's why that's why we call this
an inferior good these other two cars
these other two cars when so that's
price and this is demand these other two
cars when income went up so if this was
the demand curve at first if this is the
demand curve at first when income went
up demand went up the whole curve got
shifted to the right so they are normal
so this these are normal goods